Speaker 1: Yesterday, I reported to you that
the United States is banning Russian oil imports
and will have video a little bit later of
Joe Biden announcing that. We also have now
learned that the United Kingdom will be banning
Russian oil imports as well in a new sanctions
move. When you look at a map like the one
we have on the screen right now. You see the
significant dependance on Russian oil from
much of Eastern Europe, in particular Poland
and Hungary and other countries, Western Europe
much less reliant on Russian oil. And so saying
we are not going to accept Russian oil imports
a much less impactful decision, although still
having a major impact on oil markets also
over the last 24 hours. Maria Barra Nova,
the now former editor in chief of Russia today,
which is state run media. You might know it
as R.T. Maria Barra Nova has now resigned
as the editor in chief of R.T after condemning
the invasion of Ukraine. She is well aware
that anyone who speaks out against the Kremlin
could be in danger, but personal safety is
the least of her concerns, she said. The problem
is, I know these people very well. They never
send threats. They just kill. So there is
a kind of weird silence around me, but I really
think we're on the brink of a nuclear war
right now. I'm not exaggerating. I have a
son. I can't leave because his father won't
allow me to leave with them, so I just prefer
to stay in Moscow. It seems like we're either
in North Korea or we're going to be killed
by a thermonuclear mushroom. I wouldn't quit
and I wouldn't lose my salary and job if I
were sure that we are going to be alive for
many years. But I really don't know what is
going to happen to all of us next. Unbelievable.
Unbelievable situation. And you know, at the
at the beginning, the question was, would
will this be days or will this be weeks? More
recently, the conversation is will this be
weeks or will it be months? With some analysis
from foreign ministries briefing lawmakers
that this could be years. To some degree.
So we will watch it every 24 hours. Bringing
significant news and the refugee crisis is
getting absolutely heartbreaking to an even
greater extent than it was last week. And
we're going to talk about more. We'll talk
more about the refugee situation on tomorrow's
show. In the meantime, let me know how long
do you believe the current state of affairs
will last in Ukraine? Let me know on Twitter
where you can find me at Packman. The David
Pakman show is community supported media.
You, you are part of that community, and I
would love it if you signed up at join Packman
dot com and grabbed a membership. We do an
extra show every day. We've got this show,
the one hour podcast, which is free to everybody,
but then we do an additional show for our
members. You also get The Daily Show six hours
earlier than everybody else when you sign
up at join Packman Gqom. Yesterday, I reported
to you that the United States would be banning
Russian oil imports. And within hours of that,
the U.S. did indeed ban Russian oil imports,
and it did again send oil prices up. And we
are continuing to see nominally record gas
prices, and we may soon see inflation adjusted
record gas prices. We're not there yet, but
I will let you know when we do get there.
Yesterday, a Joe Biden made a public statement
announcing the sanctions, but in addition,
Joe Biden said during his statement, Russia's
not going to take Ukraine, Putin's not going
to win. And of course, many people liked hearing
this, but it also raises questions about,
well, how far is Joe Biden willing to go to
make sure that that's the case? That's the
question we'll discuss in a moment. Here's
Joe Biden yesterday.
Speaker 2: That'll mean tyrants like Fool
won't be able to use fossil fuels as weapons
against other nations, and it will make America
a world leader. Manufacturing and exporting
clean energy technologies of the future to
countries all around the world. This is the
goal we should be racing toward. Over the
last two weeks, the Ukrainian people have
inspired the world, and I mean that in a literal
sense, they've inspired the world with their
bravery, their patriotism, defiant determination
to live free. Putin's war Putin's war has
caused enormous suffering and needless loss
of life of women, children and everyone in
Ukraine. Both Ukraine and I might add Russians,
Ukrainian leaders, as well as leaders around
the world, have repeatedly called for a cease
fire for humanitarian relief or real diplomacy.
But Putin seemed determined to continue on
his murderous path. No matter the cost, Putin's
now targeting cities and has been targeting
citizens, civilians, schools, hospitals, apartment
buildings. Last week, he attacked the largest
nuclear power plant in Europe with an apparent
disregard for the potential of triggering
a nuclear meltdown. He has already turned
to many Ukrainians and refugees. Russia may
continue to grind out its advance at a horrible
price, but this much is already clear. Ukraine
will never be a victory for Putin,
Speaker 1: so of course we all want to believe.
While most of us may be the guy going to play
a clip of a dozen, but most of us want to
believe that that's the case, that this you
can't do what Putin has done and win and get
away with it and annex or take over Ukraine
or install a puppet puppet government or whatever
the case may be. The question is, can Joe
Biden really be sure of that without ever
committing U.S. troops to Ukraine now? From
the beginning, I've said I don't want U.S.
troops going to Ukraine. And Joe Biden has
said US troops will not go to Ukraine. There's
no question about that. I'm not changing that
or arguing against that. The question is,
is Joe Biden in a position to guarantee that
Vladimir Putin will not take Ukraine? And
at the same time, be sure that that is possible
without even potentially committing troops
to the fight? I don't know the answer to that.
It's sort of an empirical question about the
military power and what NATO's potentially
willing to do now. Of course, there's this
in-between, right? Where. The U.S. is part
of Naito, and is there some technically accurate
scenario in which the U.S. doesn't send troops
to Ukraine in a direct sense, but does through
Naito? If Naito chooses to enter and then
it becomes, it's almost like a semantic question,
right? Are those U.S. troops because they're
fighting under Naito or not? It becomes a
semantic question, but the question remains
How can Joe Biden really ensure Putin doesn't
win without being willing to send troops?
And is that militarily logical? And I don't
have the answer. There's different opinions
about that, depending on what military analysts
opinions you follow. One other clip I want
to play for you, as I did mentioned yesterday,
Joe Biden announcing the ban on Russian oil
and gas imports.
Speaker 2: We're banning all imports of Russian
oil and gas and energy. That means Russian
oil will no longer be acceptable at U.S. ports,
and the American people will deal another
powerful blow to Putin's war machine. This
is a move that has strong bipartisan support
in Congress, and I believe in the country.
Americans have rallied support, have rallied
to support the Ukrainian people and made it
clear we will not be part of subsidizing Putin's
war. This made we made this decision in close
consultation with our allies and our partners
around the world, particularly in Europe,
because a united response to Putin's aggression
has been my overriding focus to keep all Naito
and all the EU and our allies totally united.
Speaker 1: So the question about what will
happen with gas prices is a real question.
As I have said to many of you before, you
know, I I don't play political games with
this stuff. OK? As I've said to you before,
when gas prices are up 12 cents and Republicans
go crazy and say this is our death knell and
an attack on the middle class, we do the math
and we look at the average number of miles
driven by the average person. And what we're
talking about over the period of a month from
a 12 cent increase in gas prices is a few
bucks, OK? And for most people, it doesn't
make a real difference in terms of their budget.
We are now talking about something different.
We are now talking about gas already averaging.
I believe it was yesterday was 419 a gallon.
I think now we're up to 429 a gallon and could
be going up to five 20. We are now talking
about significantly more expensive gas that
will start having an impact on many people's
monthly budgets because of trucking expenses.
Also increasing it will have trickle down
impact on products that people are buying
now. What is there any upside? The upside
is that after I mean, listen, at this point,
it's probably been close to a month of increasing
crude oil prices as of right now. As of this
moment of me recording today's show, crude
oil prices are down five percent. And what
this could be is that, well, everything that
can be done has basically been done, and the
crude oil market is essentially a futures
market. It reflects what do we expect about
the supply of oil in the future? And we've
seen the price of crude oil continually go
up as expectations for supply crunches are
priced in. As we hear announcements about
what's going to be done, we may and I might
end up eating my hat when crude oil gets to
150 or 200 bucks per barrel. We hit 124 yesterday.
We're now down to 117. It's conceivable that
the uncertainty has all now been priced in.
We just don't know. And again, that's just
based on what's going on literally as of this
moment, with crude oil down five percent.
So the announcement is made. And we it, it
is a serious thing and it is a global issue.
It is not Joe Biden's fault. As I explained
to
you yesterday,